[Musique]
les techniques ont bien sûr évolué
depuis l'époque de la chanson mais c'est
toujours à la même saison que l'on
plante les choux nous sommes dans les
champs de la choucrouterie claude la
seule du sundgau
chaque année ce sont 1 6600 tonnes de
choux qui seront cultivées pour produire
800 tonnes de savoureuses choucroute et
des champ à l'assiette du consommateur
c'est chou n'auront guère parcouru plus
de quelques dizaines de kilomètres il
faut dire que cette choucrouterie la
dernière du haut-rhin à cultiver ses
propres légumes a fait le choix du
circuit court tant pour la production
que pour la distribution
cette choucroute à dos collé vendus en
grande distribution en boucherie en
collectivité et on a une partie qui
vient acheter la marchandise en en
direct chez nous comme on a un magasin
de vente directe
ça nous permet de garder un contrôle sur
les prix et puis on essaye aussi donc de
de se faire connaître
que les gens sachent qu'ils mangent un
produit vraiment locale c'est une
solution pour nous pour valoriser nos
produits
quand on fait du maintenant du goût du
gros volumes en vrac on voit mal comme
ça a été avec le un peu avait avec le
lay a déposé il ya des moments il ya
plus prix produire moins mais réduire le
nombre d'intermédiaires distribués
localement et valoriser qualité et
terroir sur les objectifs que se fixe
aujourd'hui nombre d'agriculteurs une
solution face à la crise agricole pour
les petites et moyennes exploitations
dans le canton de masevaux le monde
agricole innove depuis longtemps en la
matière c'est un canton rural agricole
mais qui a su prendre le problème à bras
le corps il y a déjà quelques années et
les circuits courts ou la filière courte
c'est une réalité du quotidien ici et
chaque chaque producteur chaque
agriculteur a su se diversifier et
s'adapter à l'évolution de la demande
des usagers
nous sommes maintenant au gaec des
rivières un commerce dans une
exploitation typique de la vallée de la
largue
ici on produit du lait et des céréales
vendues en coopérative et depuis une
quinzaine d'années du pain paysan et des
veaux de lait fond du circuit
nous commercialisons donc cette viande
de qualité en circuit court dans deux
grandes surfaces est également en marche
et est en vente à la ferme en caissettes
de 10 kg si bien sûr il a fallu
s'adapter aux contraintes et gagner la
confiance des supermarchés pour les cinq
associés du gaec des rivières
l'expérience est concluante
cette activité leur assure des revenus
plus certain que ceux soumis aux
variations des cours du lait et des
céréales
un plus en période de crise mais pas que
c'est un réel plus dans dans la dans la
vie de d'agriculteurs parce que nous
allons directement à la rencontre des
clients et ses clients nous nous
renforce donne de la crédibilité dans
notre métier et
nous rendent nous rend de fiers de faire
des produits de qualité c'est une
relation humaine avec aussi les bouchers
et qui comprennent nos difficultés et
qui arrive à revendre notre produit en
lui donnant une belle image et donc
c'est ça qui est important
la petite commune de gommersdorf compte
encore 11 exploitations agricoles un
chiffre élevé de nos jours si ici
l'agriculture se porte mieux qu'ailleurs
c'est aussi parce qu'ici la dcri
culteurs ont su trouver des
interlocuteurs auprès des collectivités
locales parmi ces acteurs de
l'aménagement du territoire le
département qui a toujours cherché à
promouvoir une agriculture diversifiée
notamment au travers du jer plan géré
plan veut dire le plan de gestion des
espaces ruraux pour permettre le
maintien des espaces pâturer ou
désherbage dans dans les secteurs
agricoles pour préserver l'élevage
et puis la diversification agricole
soutient différentes filières comme
fruits et légumes où la culture des
végétaux et puis aussi pour préserver
les espaces plantés les espaces vergers
pour les fruits et la production de ce
type de produit pour la
commercialisation
ouvert en 2006 l'abattoir départemental
de cernay et un de ces outils qui
permettent aux filières locales
d'exister pour preuve c'est ici que sont
abattus les veaux de lait du gaec des
rivières sans cela il faudrait aller
dans le nord de l'alsace ou en allemagne
un coût supplémentaire difficile à
supporter pour nombre d'exploitations
cet outil nous a permis de préserver
l'élevage dans nos différents
territoires de notre département car les
différentes crises successives
effectivement qu'on subit nos éleveurs
la filière courte hapiot permis
effectivement la préservation économique
de ces gens là c'est un abattoir
multi-espèces donc c'est assez compliqué
c'est une diversité effectivement
d'animaux et surtout des diversités de
prestations aussi de découpe parce que
nous faisons derrière de la caissette
permettant à chaque éleveur
effectivement de commercialiser si
longtemps
sans cette structure financée par des
fonds publics la filière courte viande
ne pourrait pas exister dans le haut
rhin
autre spécificité ici on ne parle pas de
clients les agriculteurs sont des
usagers qui sont environ 2000
contrairement à tous les abattoirs que
l'on peut connaître en france qui ont
des soucis et qui sont décriés notre
abattoir nous l'avons confié en gestion
aux éleveurs eux-mêmes qui sont
respectueux de cet outil qui est
indispensable pour leur filière alors
bien sûr le fait ceux gérés par les
éleveurs c'est une de l'aca une
responsabilité qui leur incombe qui
permet effectivement de ce côté-là
d'être et transparent
l'objectif du fonctionnement de cet
abattement n'est pas faire du bénéfice
mais de préserver l'autonomie de cet
outil et surtout toutes les
améliorations techniques
nous nous rendons maintenant dans la
vallée de la doller guewenheim chez
adrien tritter voilà près de vingt ans
que sur cette exploitation les fruits
rouges sont vendus en circuit très court
les deux tiers de la production sont
vendus directement aux clients qui
viennent les cueillir une approche qui
rapproche le producteur et le
consommateur
oui ça change beaucoup de choses déjà de
voir le consommateur de pouvoir parler
avec lui de lui montrer différentes
variétés qu'ils puissent goûter
différentes fraises voir là des produits
de saison aussi également c'est
important beaucoup viennent ici cueillir
avec leurs enfants pour leur montrer qu
est ce que ça des fruits si la vente
directe paris plus de souplesse à
l'exploitant l'agriculture reste soumise
au bon vouloir de la nature nous sommes
forcément très dépendant du temps et
cette saison il a fait plusieurs fois
très froid et sa gelée énormément ici
sur les cerises et nous avons au moins
80 pour cent de perte par exemple cette
année c'est pas tous les ans comme ça
mais payant du gel de la grève
voilà donc on fait avec on remonte dans
la vallée à dos le rhin sur les pentes
du massif est ce la trentaine de vaches
laitières de valérie et roger
trommenschlager dans cette exploitation
typique de la vallée ont produit du lait
une partie est transformée sur place en
liga ou aux flancs ou encore byblos
casse d'ici quelques mois le couple se
lancera dans la production de fromage
transforme ainsi l'intégralité de sa
production laitière sur la ferme
le fait de de tout transformer à la
ferme en montagne c'est à la fois
comment dire c'est un choix qui
s'imposent pour être compétitif enfin on
n'arrive pas en termes de production en
termes de quantité de production on
n'arrive pas à être compétitif
du coup il faut qu'on dégage la valeur
ajoutée aux ligues de l'est du coup la
transformation du lait souvent elles
s'imposent et ensuite je pense que je
pense que c'est aussi cesser une chance
quand on présente un produit quand on
est maître jusqu'au consommateur
je pense qu'on peut vraiment en être
fier or de laval et donc qui la vallée
de masevaux qui fait partie du canton de
masevaux
c'est vrai que les producteurs les
éleveurs pratique depuis de longues
années ce circuit court les gens sont
attachés connaissent les producteurs et
vont bien sûr au plus court pour pour
trouver leurs produits on a différents
circuits tout d'abord la vente directe
donc là on livre à l'ont fait beaucoup
de tournées dans la vallée on fait
presque chaque jour une tournée mais
avec des secteurs différents dans la
vallée donc du porte à porte ou on
dépose chez les gens la commande qu'ils
ont
qu'ils ont passés ensuite nous avons un
certain nombre de marchés
à cela s'ajoute également quelques
points de livraison dans des commerces
mais également un magasin de producteurs
le ge les champs de lille hp ce bar le
bas tient un magasin dont nous sommes
associé avec d'autres agriculteurs pour
pouvoir présenter des produits fermiers
le circuit court c'est de façon de
permettre aux producteurs et aux
éleveurs de vivre de leur travail et de
rester dans cette vallée au département
on souhaite aller plus avant dans le
soutien à ces filières dans l'enjeu
économique social et environnemental est
important le département lui profite de
cette filière courte parce qu'on
aimerait trouver les produits qui sont
produits donc dans le canton on aimerait
le retrouver dans sur la table de nos
collégiens
donc on encourage fortement les collèges
à aller vers les producteurs locaux pour
trouver les produits qui vont servir
alors qui sait peut-être
retrouverez-vous d'ici quelques temps
certains de ses produits dans les
assiettes de vos enfants